in the fourth quarter of 2019 companies
on the S&P 500 spent an estimated one
hundred and eighty nine billion dollars
buying back their own shares from the
stock market it was the highest in three
quarters but not the highest on record
in the final quarter of 2018 the number
was about two hundred and twenty three
billion a high point on a decade-long
trend in all since 2010 companies on the
S&P have poured more than 5.3 trillion
dollars into repurchasing their own
shares
analysts say buybacks have been a
driving force in the decade-long bull
market but there's some argument over
whether they're good for the economy
skeptics say the money used on stock
buybacks would be better spent elsewhere
like building new factories are
exploring new opportunities altogether
meanwhile proponents say buybacks are
putting money right where it belongs
with shareholders to understand the
debate you have to understand how stock
buybacks work
[Music]
the debate around stock buy box has to
do with how companies use their cash
they have access to quite a bit of it
right now
the tax cuts in 2017 relatively high
earnings and low interest rates have all
added to corporate cash stockpiles when
a company is flush and has options for
what to do with its money it can buy
other companies it can spend on research
and development it can buy new equipment
buildings or technologies or it can
return money to shareholders this can
take the form of dividends or stock
buybacks in the past ten years the top
20 companies on the S&P 500 bought back
about 1.3 trillion in shares with Apple
leading the way by far in a stock
buyback a company purchases its own
shares from shareholders and it takes
them off the market leaving fewer shares
outstanding
this changes the math on the remaining
shares in a key Wyck it boosts a metric
called earnings per share or EPS the
most basic equation for EPS is the
company's net income divided by the
number of outstanding shares so when
this number shrinks the EPS Rises so if
a company has a net income of $1,000 and
has 100 shares outstanding its EPS is 10
dollars but if it buys back 10 of those
shares the EPS rises to 11 dollars in 11
cents higher per share earnings makes
stocks look good an analyst at the S&P
Dow Jones indices said that a little
more than 1 in 5 companies on the S&P
500 reduced share counts by at least 4
percent through buybacks in the most
recent quarter boosting earnings per
share stock buybacks can be a good deal
for remaining shareholders they tend to
benefit executives because rising stock
prices make their stock options more
valuable this is one of the criticisms
of stock buybacks the people who decide
what to do with the extra cash often
stand to benefit skeptics say that money
is better used on growing the company
here's a chart that looks at the change
in business investment since 2013 you
can see it's gone negative three times
critics of buybacks say the practice is
partly to blame for the lagging business
investment and 2019 Democratic senators
Chuck Schumer and Bernie Sanders argued
that buybacks restrain companies from
investing in R&D equipment higher wages
paid medical leave retirement benefits
and worker training and Republican
Senator Marco Rubio of Florida unveiled
a proposal that would change how
investors are taxed when companies buy
back shares analysts also say that
another worrying sign is that buybacks
have coincided with a rise in corporate
debt levels some worry that companies
are taking out debt to finance the stock
buybacks proponents of buybacks say
there's no real link between share
repurchases and tepid capital investment
and that companies could be deferring
investment for other reasons maybe
they're pessimistic about future demand
and economic growth and they don't see
attractive investment opportunities for
the company this camp says that if a
company sees no profitable use of their
money they should return it to
shareholders we then have the choice to
invest it on more profitable ventures
some also say the rise in buybacks is
overstated companies regularly issue
stock as part of compensation and the
rise and buyback is partly served to
offset those new shares as this debate
continues one thing is clear buy backs
are now a big part of the landscape of
American Finance there's no sign that
that's about to change